[Music]
Kim Kardashian's not a regular mom mama
Colma taking her kiddos all the way to
Tokyo for spring break where they got
matching Hello Kitty nails and hit up a
hedgehog Cafe I don't know what's gonna
top that the reality star documents the
family trip to Japan on Tick Tock
including her sweet matching Manny with
her nine-year-old daughter North
[Music]
the ladies opted for some cute Hello
Kitty embellishments which were on full
display in another clip where Kim North
and Kourtney Kardashian's daughter
Penelope shared some Hello Kitty treats
grape juice and ice cream we you know
have always stayed true to who we are
and always shared pretty much everything
the crew had dinner at a ninja themed
restaurant that's Kim's seven-year-old
son Saint entering the venue while
five-year-old Chicago flashed a peace
sign at the table the fam notched on
yummy food and North flashed her fancy
nails for the camera one more time it's
really fun to see and file this under
not your average spring break activity
Kim and the kiddos playing with
hedgehogs and rats posing for the camera
and feeding their tiny new friends some
grub having kids is just there's no way
to describe it but it's a lot but it's
not the first time Kim's gone above and
beyond to show her little one's a good
time earlier this month Kim took soccer
obsessed Saint overseas to London to
watch England's Arsenal play Portugal
Sporting Lisbon
[Applause]
the proud mama shared a series of snaps
from the game including this moment of
Saint and his friends chanting defense
me back
of course Kim shares four kids with her
ex Kanye West North Saint Chicago and
Psalm Kim's currently single but yay
married Bianca sensory in a private but
unofficial ceremony in January as for
co-parenting a source previously told ET
that Kim wants Kanye to be at peace so
if Bianca helps with that then it's fine
they do have
you know a family that I have to just be
positive and get it together for
et's Insider says the former couple is
still having some back and forth
arguments we have different views
sometimes we have different things but
co-parenting in a healthy way is Kim's
primary focus you know it's hard
it's like co-parenting it's really hard
you know it's something Kim opened up
about back in December during a chat on
Angie Martinez's IRL podcast
I definitely protected him and I still
will in
the eyes of my kids for my kids so in my
home my kids don't know anything that
goes on on the outside world as for love
ET Source says the mama four is open to
it why not but she's looking for someone
that adds to her life
foreign
[Music]